hey everyone my name is quintessa
Swindell and I play Maxine hunkle AKA
Cyclone I'm Pierce Brosnan I play Dr
Fate I'm Dwayne Johnson and I play Black
Adam aldisage I play Hawkman I'm Noah
centineo and I play Adam Smasher and
we're here with BuzzFeed to take a quiz
and find out which DC villain we are
pick the location of your villainous
Lair there's a concealed Castle a
futuristic Tower a secluded tunnel an
icy Igloo like it's Club Penguin an
abandoned building and inside of a
volcano that's mine you took volcano I
took off a good one I'm going with
futuristic Tower I want to be
comfortable I like a Butte you know what
I'm saying with an embedded building you
know I've got a concealed Castle I don't
mean I've got a concealed car so many
concealed cars Pierce and I are one I'm
going with a concealed Castle
all right so next question what would
your friend say is your greatest shrink
sense of humor compassion loyalty good
listener honesty or sense of adventure I
would say not how they describe you is
not here yeah it's not here at all not
at all why are these all positive yeah
right I'm gonna lie in his passion I'm
gonna lie too I'm gonna go with
compassion all right cool you can't beat
loyal sense of adventure
damn did I take yours how do I go back
can I switch no no no no no no no no no
I switch it I'm a good listener it's
permanent now we're all lying I'm gonna
lie
uh yeah sense of adventure bro you don't
have to change it though I changed it
I'm following my heart
I picked the Disney villain you most
enjoy watching
he's really good so the list of villains
here scar of course uh Ursula Gaston
Maleficent Dr facilier isma yeah
and she goes yes
I'm gonna go with Gaston okay I have to
pick score yeah I'm watching on scars
yeah
I can't lie I feel like my whole mood is
easy
how could you not pick the Dragon
Speaking of Disney villains every
villain needs a song right so which
iconic song would you choose to sing a
karaoke Thriller Michael Jackson dancing
queen Abba Break My Soul by Beyonce
Savage by Megan three stallion Eye Of
The Tiger by Survivor Lose Yourself by
Eminem wow it's between Thriller and eye
of the tiger but for some reason I gotta
go eye of the tiger I am a dagger
[Music]
yeah it's good too oh okay I'm a little
saddened by the fact that Rage Against
the Machine isn't on this list right you
know Paul's on parade is it that's a
good one it's a fun one to do I'm gonna
go Savage by Megan to style also
expected
I just feel like I know you you know
what I'm saying because I'm Savage
you're a Savage I'm Savage classic I
gotta go with the eye of the tiger too
pick the main color on your super cool
costume I used to be blue black
red
I'm going black green but with pink
accents oh look the options are black
red green purple blue pink you gonna
pick Green
why why Cyclone wears green yeah exactly
exactly you sure it's not pink I don't
know like a pink costume that's true
total pink costume it's a little intense
the pink costume is intense but pink
eyebrows are fly as hell no it's not a
truth this is the truth I'm actually
going to switch mine from red to Pink
okay no that was unexpected unexpected
I'm always trying to keep you on your
toes finally pick the DC Comics hero
that despite your villainous ways you
still kind of admire we got Superman we
got Wonder Woman we got Batman we got
Batgirl we got Aquaman and Shazam
Batgirl
Batman
loved by me I'm gonna say Batgirl I'm
going Batman I gotta go Aquaman
[Music]
my villain is so chaotic I love it oh
wait y'all go y'all go yeah well who's
yours I got the Joker I got the Joker
too did you really yeah oh my God I love
it I got black guys
that's great what'd you get Dwayne you
got Aries God of War yeah that would be
a cool battle Black Adam and Aries I
think I got you a pawn shop
sometimes trying to figure it out what I
got you gotta hit Batman right there
right back to the beginning went back to
the beginning
I said that without moving my lips yeah
all right guys that is a wrap for us go
enjoy Black Adam in theaters around the
world on October 21st you guys are gonna
love it Black Adam the JSA here they all
are in the flesh can't wait for you guys
to see it enjoy
foreign
[Music]